(mysterious electronic music)
- Okay everyone, greetings.
Nice to see you all.
Welcome to the fourth lecture.
As you'll remember,
section starts this week.
Somewhat incredibly we
have a Pole, a Ukrainian,
and a Lithuanian TF-ing in this class,
which honestly could not have been,
I mean, if I'd tried to do that,
there's no way that could
have actually happened.
So your TFs will be the
beautiful and talented,
Zhenia Monastyrskyi.
Zhenia, say hello.
There you go, that's Zhenia.
- [Zhenia] We already met.
- Oh, okay.
The equally beautiful and
talented Wiktor Babinski,
and the no less beautiful
and talented Maksimas Milta.
These are your three TFs.
Get to know them, get to love them,
figure out what the bribery culture is
in their various countries,
and adapt yourself to it.
Lots of laughter from the
Ukrainians there, that's a clue.
(audience laughing)
That's a clue.
I do not have time for
funny bribery stories.
If there's time at the end of the lecture,
I'll tell you a funny bribery story.
Okay, so welcome.
We are working our way now
towards proper history.
I've been trying to set
up some of the concepts
because the longer I've
been doing this job,
the more it seems to me
that we have to think about
what history is before we
jump into doing the subject.
And so I've been using the fact
that we're in the moment
in the middle of a war
to try to help the, I've
been trying to use the war
to like shake up the concepts
and to help us think about
how things are fluid,
and also help us to think about
how we talk and how we think about things
may influence the world
more than we realize, right?
That the unthinking or half thinking ways
that we approach the past
will affect the decisions
that we make in the future
by determining how we see
things in the present.
But this is also really important,
because Ukraine is, you
know, for many of you,
a new subject.
And even for those of you
who it's not a new subject,
it's unlikely that you've
actually had a class
that was just about Ukrainian history.
Did anybody check how many classes
in Ukrainian history there are?
- [Student] I couldn't find any.
- Okay, so I'm holding one lecture class
in the United States of
America on modern Ukraine,
which is an extraordinary thing, right?
If you think about it.
It raises the question of
what has gone wrong with us
in general, right?
Like, no, why is it that what we do
is so mismatched with the
world around us, right?
Like don't you feel ill served?
If you're going to any, I mean,
okay, not everybody at
Yale is in this class,
but isn't it odd to
think that if you were at
any other university in the United States,
you wouldn't even be able
to take a class in Ukraine,
even though, right?
And that raises the larger question of
why is it, in the 21st century,
where we supposedly have
access to all this data
all the time, and we all
know everything instantly,
why are we always
surprised by things, right?
Why is it that things
that happen in the world
always seem to catch us unprepared?
And so you know what my
answer for that is gonna be,
my answer for that is gonna be
that you should all be history majors.
Because if you're a history
major, or just take,
I don't care whether
you're a major or not,
just take a bunch of history classes,
because you'll be less
likely to be surprised
by the things that happen to you
over the course of your life.
Like, if nothing else, it'll
help you not be surprised
by stuff that happens.
Okay, our job today is to set up Europe.
You know, if you're looking at it from
the point of view of today
you could be thinking, well,
is Ukraine Europe, is Europe Ukraine.
We're not there yet.
We're thinking about
the world before Europe,
because Ukraine, Kyivan Rus,
which we're gonna get
to in the next lecture,
Kyivan Rus is coming into being at a time
when the notion of Europe
doesn't really exist yet,
and wouldn't really make any sense.
So I'm gonna start by talking
about a couple of ways that people look at
the sequence of events that led to Europe.
Then I'm gonna move on to the things
which really were there before Europe.
I'm gonna talk about language for a bit,
I'm gonna talk about
pre-Christian religion for a bit,
and then I'm going to
move towards the story
of how this state came into being.
So there are, if you are
in, broadly speaking,
the trajectory of Western Europe,
the United States, or North America,
the way that the trajectory
of European history is taught
begins with ancient Greece.
And I'm not gonna change that here.
We're also gonna be talking
about ancient Greece.
I'm just gonna be messing
with it a little bit.
I did the whole thing with the olive tree
and the trident already, right?
Did I do that in an earlier
lecture? No, I didn't do that?
Okay.
So I did or I didn't?
You're the only one
who remembers it, okay.
Maybe the entire class has
switched out since then,
and you're the only,
like this was a really
aggressive shopping period,
they're all new.
Okay, so just to remind
you, of Athens itself,
the founding story of Athens itself,
involves an olive tree and a trident.
It involves a contest between
Athena, the goddess Athena,
and Poseidon, who gets to be the namesake.
You know the answer because
the city is not called,
you know, Poseidon, it's called Athens.
So Athena wins because
she gives the Athenians
an olive tree, and the Athenians say
this is very nice,
shade, olive oil, right?
Poseidon strikes his
trident on the ground,
and seawater springs
forward, springs forth.
And the Athenians say that
doesn't taste very good,
we're not really into that.
That's the way the story goes, right?
That's the way the story goes.
And it brings you an image of Athens
which is peaceful and contemplative
and maybe tending
towards consumer society.
It's a certain image of democracy, right?
Whereas Poseidon is offering, you know,
strife, and sea commerce, and war,
and navies, and things like that.
Now, underneath that story is a question.
Because, you know, all societies
in the way that they tell
their story of founding
are hiding something, right?
And this little story, what's being hidden
is the answer to the question:
how can you possibly live
just on olive oil, right?
You can't.
I mean, no, yes?
I mean, at least you need a little bread
at least with the olive oil.
And so where was the bread coming from?
I'm now gonna see if
anybody was at this lecture.
Where was the bread coming from?
Where were the calories
actually coming from?
The grain?
Yes.
- [Student] The Southern Ukraine, right?
- Right, what's now Southern Ukraine.
The northern coast.
So the ancient world,
the ancient Greek world,
includes the Black Sea,
up to and including the
north Black Sea coast,
which is now Southern Ukraine.
That's where the calories came from.
And so you can plant
your little city state
full of olive trees,
because you're engaged in
an international trade,
and you're getting your
calories from somewhere else.
So this isn't just mark
that, that's important,
because the connection
of our part of the world
with other parts of the world
by way of food and calories
is enduring.
So for the ancient Greeks,
what we're calling Ukraine was a place.
And if you did your reading
of the Serhii Plokhy
you'll know that for Herodotus,
who was a major source,
the ancient historian Herodotus,
along with Thucydides the two, you know,
the two people who found history, as such.
Herodotus maps what we call
Ukraine in a certain way,
correctly, which is sea,
coast, steppe, and forest,
moving from south to north, right?
Sea, coast, steppe and forest.
And the further north you go,
the more exotic it is, right?
So from the point of view
of that civilization,
northward means more exotic.
And so it's in the North
that a lot of the Greek
mythology is located,
a lot of like the
Elysian Fields are there,
and the Mountains of Hyperborea are there,
griffins are there, all
kinds of stuff is there.
The Scythians, they locate,
I didn't write the Scythians,
the Scythians are also there.
The Scythians are, in fact, real.
And they did inhabit what's
now Ukraine at the time
and they did fantastic work in gold.
So that part, the part about Ukraine
being rich in gold is not entirely false.
The treasures of the
Scythians still exist,
they're still in museums,
they're being looted in this war.
So there are a lot of ways in which
what happens in the war
actually reminds us of things
that were a couple of thousand years ago,
like the Scythians, for example.
There's a museum in
Ukraine which was looted,
and the Scythian gold work has
now been taken off to Russia.
Okay, so the Greeks are already
looking at the territory
that we think of as Ukraine,
and they already have a certain
geographical view of it,
which is south to north. And I
want you to think about this,
because we are, you
know, we are in the West,
and so when we look at
Ukraine we're thinking, okay,
West Ukraine, East Ukraine.
But from the point of view of our story,
south to north and north to south
is actually much more important,
at least for the first
few weeks of this class.
Okay, so if you're looking,
so taking ancient Greece
as a starting point,
if you're now looking at
this whole thing from today,
but from a Western point of view,
there's a certain way that
ancient Greece connects to you,
and this will be familiar to you probably,
it goes like this:
there was Greece, and then there was Rome,
and then Rome fell, right?
Very dramatic, it fell.
Imagine all the buildings falling, right?
It's a very dramatic image, Rome fell.
It was overrun by barbarians,
it ceased to exist, right?
Very dramatic.
And then nothing happened for a while,
and then there was a Renaissance,
or there were Dark Ages and
then there was a Renaissance,
and then that Renaissance miraculously,
the clever Europeans discovered
all those things that were lost.
They discovered the Greek
stuff, and the Roman stuff,
and they, so I told you before,
always be skeptical of
this rebirth metaphor,
because if you think about
rebirth for one second,
it's really creepy, right?
I mean, just birth itself, honestly.
Like, I don't know how
many of you have seen one,
but it's a thing.
And then think about
doing it twice with the,
I mean it's just, so be
suspicious of rebirth metaphors,
including the Renaissance.
So anyway, this is a
Western perspective, right?
Greece, Rome, Rome falls,
then there's a Renaissance where
everything is rediscovered,
and then after the
Renaissance comes nations,
and the nations, the French, the Italians,
the British, and so on,
all in some way look back to
ancient Greece to this pattern.
If you're in our part of the
world, this looks different.
You can still start with
ancient Greece, as I say.
There's Rome, there's
ancient Greece, there's Rome.
So far, so good.
Does Rome fall?
- [Student] No.
- No, never falls.
Yeah, okay (laughs).
There's like one solid supporter
of Byzantium over here.
I'm glad.
(students laughing)
That's right, Rome does not fall, right?
Rome doesn't fall, the
buildings don't all fall,
the Colosseum doesn't
fall, it's still there,
you can visit it today, trust me.
It doesn't all fall down,
the barbarians don't all
come rushing in one day
and have a barbarian party.
That never happens.
Part of the Roman Empire
slowly falls under the
influence of others.
The capital of Rome moves to the city
which is today known as Istanbul,
but which for a long time
was known as Constantinople.
And the Roman Empire continues
as Byzantium, as Byzantium.
It continues for another thousand years,
which let's face it,
even if we're cynical,
is a pretty long time.
And that thing which is
called the Renaissance,
where the clever Europeans
like rediscover all the things,
the Renaissance is possible,
you know, in large measure,
because Rome never fell
in the first place,
because there was, there's no,
I'm not gonna say the
Byzantium preserved everything
of ancient Greece and
ancient Rome, it didn't,
but it preserved a lot of things,
like for example the Iliad.
So if you've had like any kind of like,
if you've done, you know, DS here,
have had any kind of
that sort of education,
the Iliad only exists,
that's the story of the
Trojan War with Achilles
and all these figures,
the Iliad only exists
because people for a
thousand years in Byzantium
hand copied the thing over,
and over, and over, and over,
and over, and over, and
over, and over, and over,
and over, and over, and over again, right?
Until late in the day copies
were transferred to Italy
right before Byzantium
was overcome, let's say.
And then they were printed
in Italy and translated
and then it becomes a classic text.
And so therefore, because of Byzantium,
we have Achilles, we have the
Iliad, we have Homer, right?
And we can say, oh, we rediscovered it,
isn't that wonderful?
And we can do that kind
of time travel magic
where we leap back to ancient Greece.
But it's less time travel magic
if you remember that
Byzantium was actually around
for another thousand years.
And for our story, for
our East European story,
you just can't do without
Byzantium in the middle.
If you're telling this story
from a Western point of view
it's kind of awkward that
Byzantium is still there, right?
It's kind of awkward.
It's like you're trying
to like date a new person
but you're still going
out with the other person
but it's like, I'm not
really, you know, not really,
like you know, she's not, not, you know?
And that's what Byzantium is
like in the Western story.
Like okay, there's this
huge thing over there,
and it calls itself Rome,
and they're speaking Greek,
but it's not really Europe.
It's not really there.
Let's just look the other way, right?
That's what Byzantium is
if you're doing the West European thing.
But if you're not, if you're
trying to figure out Ukraine,
or for that matter Russia or Belarus,
but the fact that Byzantium
is there the whole time is important.
It's not marginal, it's not
some kind of unwanted appendage,
it's not this confusing thing.
It's part of this
unbroken tradition, right?
So I was just in central Kyiv
and I was looking at the cathedral,
which is spectacularly
beautiful, St. Sophia,
and it was built, you know,
that was built in 1037, right?
It was built, you know,
it was built while
Byzantium was still around.
It was built three centuries
before Notre Dame, right?
Three centuries before Notre Dame.
The daughter of the guy who
had it built, by the way,
was Queen of France.
And she went to France and she said
this place is backward and dirty,
and I really wanna go home, right?
So that gives you, and that's
not just the kind of thing
that makes Ukrainians proud,
but it also just gives you a sense that,
for quite a while, this Byzantine story
was a heartier and more interesting story
than the West European story.
Okay, so there's a different story
starting with ancient Greece,
which is, in a way, more
robust and continuous.
I'm not saying it had to be that way.
I'm not saying that Ukraine
had to be part of the Byzantine tradition.
Other things could have happened,
but that is in fact how it turned out.
Okay, so language here
then becomes important.
In the West European version,
or the Western version,
there's Greek, right, then there's Latin,
and then from Latin you
get the Romance languages,
Portuguese, Romanian,
French, Spanish, Italian.
So the Romance languages
they're called, Rome.
And then you have the Germanic languages.
So the Germanic peoples
were some of the ones
who overwhelmed Rome, replaced
Rome actually kind of slowly.
So, you know, Danish, and Dutch,
and Swedish, German, right?
So in Western Europe, the
Western Europe is dominated,
oh English is a Germanic language, forgot.
So Western Europe is
dominated by these Germanic
and these Romance languages.
In Eastern Europe we have
a different trajectory,
which is Greek, more Greek,
a language called Old Church Slavonic,
which we'll explain more about
at the end of this lecture and next week,
and then Slavic languages.
Now Slavic languages, which
we're gonna move into,
they are par excellence something
which comes before Europe.
It has always been and is still frankly
a little mysterious
why so many people speak
Slavic languages, right?
The Slavic languages are actually
the dominant language group of Europe
if you count the people, right?
If you count the people,
or especially if you count the territory
where more people speak
it than any other, right?
Slavic languages cover
a lot more territory
than Germanic ones do
or than Romance ones do.
And the Slavic languages that were spoken
a thousand years ago are not,
are clearly related to
the Slavic languages
that are spoken now.
Okay.
Okay, what am I doing with my hand?
- [Student] Punching.
- Punching, okay.
So if you had a drink, if you had a drink,
I'm not saying that you did,
but if you had a drink on Saturday night,
and it was in a big bowl,
had some alcohol in it,
some other stuff, what was that called?
- [Student] Punch.
- Okay, why, has it ever occurred to you,
like why is this and the,
why is that the same word?
That's never occurred to you, okay.
But you know the answer.
- [Student] No, I don't, I just,
if you drink a lot of the
punch, maybe you're more likely-
(Timothy laughing)
- All right.
That is what is known as a folk etymology.
(students laughing)
Like, and the thing is like,
now that's gonna be on the internet,
and next week it's gonna be true.
(students chuckling)
It's gonna cover the,
you're gonna have taken
over the cognitive space
to that explanation.
So the reason why, okay, is that a punch
is a drink that has five ingredients.
And a punch like this, count
'em, five fingers, okay.
How do you, anyone know
how to say five in Russian?
- [Student] Pyat.
- How do you say five in Polish?
- [Student] Piec.
- Five in Ukrainian?
- [Student] Pyat.
- Okay.
That's why, all right?
It's a rare example of a base Slavic word
coming into our language, right?
So the reason why punch and punch,
we have that word, is from
Slavic languages' five,
the word for five, that's
where it comes from.
And so, interestingly, so
that raises the question
like are you speaking the
language, or is it speaking you?
Because you didn't have
to know why it's a punch,
like you would've gone through your,
if you hadn't taken this class, amazingly,
you would've gone through your whole lives
without knowing, right, why it's a punch,
and why I'm throwing a punch,
or why I'm drinking punch.
So are you speaking the language,
or does the language speak you, right?
Language is interesting because, I mean,
how many of us actually invent
a word and have it stick?
Relatively few.
Even in the age of the
internet, relatively few of us.
The language is there for us, we speak it,
or does it speak us?
And it outlasts us.
I mean when we're gone,
the language that we speak
is still going to be there.
So it's important to
kind of, it's important,
what I'm starting to say is,
to disaggregate the
language from the people.
So I'm gonna be talking about the Slavs,
and the Slavic language,
but it's important to remember that
it's not that there's a language
biologically connected to people.
The language is there
when people are born.
And whether they end up
speaking that language
or other languages are gonna depend upon
what happens to them over the
course of their lives, right?
So just to take a very easy example,
more people are speaking
Ukrainian in public now
than when I was there the last
time a year ago, noticeably.
That's not, that's because
of something that's changed
in the world, right?
It's because something
that's changed in the world.
Language is not, so
it's not the same thing,
like when languages move,
it's not necessarily
because people have moved.
It's not as simple as that.
So the way that historians tell the story
in terms of the movements of people
is not the same way that
the historical philologists
tell the story with the
movements of languages.
And historical philologists are probably,
I think, are probably right.
So language does change,
but it changes more
slowly than we do, right?
So, I mean, we can still,
we can all read Shakespeare, right?
If you're Polish, you can
easily read the Polish
of 400 years ago.
And if you're Russian or Ukrainian
or Belorussian or whatever,
you can read texts from
several hundred years ago
with just a little bit of effort.
And although it's weird to
think about vice versa, right?
Like if you could time travel people
from like 500 years ago to now,
they would understand our conversations,
at least with a little bit of work.
So the language is there
before you get there.
An example that's relevant
for our class is the Vikings.
The Vikings are speaking,
obviously, you know,
proto-Swedish, Scandinavian
languages, a Germanic language.
They arrive in Kyiv.
Don't worry, there's a
whole lecture about this,
it's the next one.
They arrive in Kyiv and the
dominant language around them
is a Slavic language.
And what do they do?
They learn it, right?
They learn it, and they take it on,
they change their own names
so that their name sounds Slavic, right?
So what could sound more
Slavic than Yaroslav, right?
Yaroslav.
But if I say Jarisleif, you
might think for a second,
say, oh, Jarisleif,
that sounds like somebody
in an Icelandic saga,
and you would be right,
and it's the same person.
Or if I say Volodymyr, you'll think, well,
that's the President
of Ukraine, Volodymyr,
that sounds very Slavic.
But what if I say Valdamar, right?
Then we're somewhere completely different.
And the guy who is
remembered by the Ukrainians
as Volodymyr, or by the
Russians as Vladimir,
was actually called Valdamar, right?
And certainly like when he, you know,
talked to his Scandinavian relatives,
that's what he was called.
So they learn the language,
they adapt their own
names to this language,
and then this language
also speaks us, right?
Then this language speaks us.
Like I was on American
television last night,
with an American, you
know, asking me questions.
And he's talking about Vladimir Putin
and Volodymyr Zelenskyy
and I'm thinking, you know,
more than a thousand years ago,
a Scandinavian called Valdamar, you know,
got himself baptized and
now we are saying Volodymyr.
Like it hasn't, my point is that
it hasn't changed that much,
and we can even kind of
explain why it changed.
Like the guy who was called Valdamar,
he took on the name, in
this language at that time
was probably something
like Voldemar, right?
But he took on a name, and
now a thousand years later
we're still, these names
are speaking through us.
Okay, you get the point.
So language is there between us
and language is helping to make us.
Now this is only possible because
some institutions outside of individuals
are keeping the language going, right?
And we're gonna talk a little about
what those institutions might have been.
But the big institutional
change is whether there are,
whether there's a written language or not,
and whether some institution
is propagating the written language.
And so a big moment of historical change
for any language is when literacy comes,
and that's where we're
gonna be edging towards.
So the conversion, in
around 988, to Christianity
is also the moment when a written language
emerges on these territories.
But, that said, you know,
it's important that there
was a Slavic language,
that it was spoken, that it
was not so terribly different
from the Slavic languages
that are spoken now.
This is a, so this is a continuity.
This is something which was
there before Kyivan Rus,
before any idea of Europe.
If there was a time traveler
from a thousand years ago
and heard Ukrainian or Russian
for that matter being spoken,
they would understand that there was,
that this language had something
to do with their language.
Now, by the way, I'm not trying to say
that Slavic was the only kind of language
being spoken then, right?
Other languages are being spoken
on the territory of Ukraine as well,
like Greek, for example.
But it was the main language then,
just as it is the main language now.
And so here we have a very
significant continuity.
Okay, what was that language,
and what can that language tell us
about the people we're concerned with?
Slavic language, so how
do we call each other?
When I was in Kyiv, I was
overhearing, as one does,
it's like an important, you
know, scientific method,
you listen in to other
people's conversations.
I was listening to a
couple of military officers
talking about like one of their colleagues
who's going off for training.
And the first guy said, you know,
he went, he said he went do Germaniyu.
And then he corrected himself,
do Nimechchyny, right?
So what was happening there is that
do Germaniyu is not really, that's like,
kind of, so that's not really Ukrainian.
It's kind of Russian.
Do Nimechchyny is Ukrainian,
to Germany is what it means.
Nimechchyny, Nimechchyna.
Why is that country called that,
why is Germany called
that in Slavic languages?
You've taken classes before.
Have you taken classes before?
Okay, why is it called that?
- [Student] Well Nemets
means kind of mute in Russian
and they couldn't understand the Germans.
- Very good.
Yeah, so a Nemets, sorry, Nemets,
it's the same in a bunch
of Slavic languages,
is somebody who can't hear you,
can't understand you, right?
So in a lot of these languages up till now
a Neme or something like that
means mute or maybe deaf,
someone who can't talk
or can't who can't hear.
So there's, so that, like that tells you
that there is this ancient barrier
between people who speak Slavic
and people who speak Germanic languages,
and that line is still there, right?
It's not where it always was.
It's probably, I'm sure
it's occurred to you,
if it hasn't it's gonna stay
with you the rest of your life,
Berlin isn't really a
very German name, right?
It's not, it's a Slavic name, right?
A lot of the toponyms
in what's now Germany
are actually Slavic names because the line
between the two languages
used to be further
to the west than it is now.
So the way people use
languages starts to tell us
where they think they are,
where they think they start,
where they think they stop.
The word for Slav, which
we're just gonna use Ukrainian
'cause this is a class on Ukraine,
but if I say Slav in
Ukrainian it's Slovyan,
and the word for word is Slovo, okay?
So as best as we can make out,
the Slavs thought of themselves
as the people who could talk, right?
The people of the word.
As opposed to the Germans
who you can't figure out
what they're saying, and you know,
they don't understand you.
So it, so like Slovyanska,
or in Polish Slowianska,
these are people, these are
the people who have the word.
And this, like this broader name,
it survived into the nations
that named themselves the latest.
So like the Slovenes
and the Slovaks, right?
Those were the Slavs who
took on national names late.
And so basically they
just took the name Slav
as opposed to other people.
Now, that word, Slav, for self,
which means people of the word
might mean something else to other people.
So in, if you are an Arab
speaking slave trader
that word means something
entirely different.
Al-Saqaliba means slaves, means slaves,
and that Arabic word then becomes the,
goes into the West
through German as Sklavin
and becomes the English word slave.
So it's actually not a coincidence
that the English word slave
sounds like the word Slav
that we're talking about.
It's not a coincidence at all.
It's historically revealing
because the people that
we're talking about
were enslaved, right, between
the Baltic and the Black Sea,
usually by slavers coming
from the north to the south,
and so an Arabic word to describe them
then comes into our language, right?
With a very different meaning.
It's very different to say
I'm the people of the word
as opposed to the people
who can be enslaved.
And although, like with the punch thing
that you could probably
do without the word punch,
but you can't really do
without the word slave.
And so here you have an example of how
the language is speaking you
and the language is carrying knowledge
of something that happened,
as it happens in our part of the world,
the language is carrying
knowledge of something
that happened in our part of the world
a thousand years ago or more, right?
And now you know what that knowledge is.
The knowledge is that the pagan Slavs
that we're talking
about, for a long while,
were enslaved, they were
legitimately enslaved.
Why do I say legitimately?
That's not a good word.
It's because the monotheistic
religions in general
did not enslave their own people.
So they might enslave other people
who are believers of other
monotheistic religions,
but not themselves.
But if you were a pagan, everyone
could enslave you, right?
If you were a Christian,
Muslims might, and pagans might,
and so on, but if you're a pagan,
then everyone might enslave
you, including the other pagans.
And so that's an important
point that raises the stakes
of this whole monotheism.
When we get to the conversion
it's not just this, like,
it's not just that people
are becoming Christian.
I mean in a way like that's
the least important thing,
and it takes a while to happen.
You're, but when you
join the Christian world
it means that other Christians
aren't going to enslave you.
And it means that you're, you know,
you're part of a larger group.
But don't worry, we'll
talk more about that later.
Okay, so the Slavs, from
their own point of view,
are the people of the word.
From the point of view
of people around them,
for a while at least, they are
people who can be enslaved.
So this brings us to what
I want to talk about next,
which is who they were at the time.
So again, before Europe,
before the conversion,
means before literacy,
so we know less about them, right?
So, I mean the history,
this may seem like a bit of a cop out,
but history is based on written records,
and so, you know, we have the history
of ancient Mesopotamia and
history of ancient Egypt,
legitimately the history,
because they left documents.
We don't have the history of
their neighbors necessarily
because their neighbors
didn't leave behind documents.
So when we're talking about
the history of the Slavs
up to this point where
the sources we're using
are Jewish travelers or
Arabic travelers, right?
Or maybe Christian missionaries,
and just the most basic principles
of source criticism would tell you that
these monotheistic visitors are gonna have
a certain kind of bias towards
the pagans that they see.
But those are the kind of
written sources we have
up until the Christian conversions.
But we know some things, but
we know less than we might.
We know something about the paganism,
but because these people were not literate
and because they didn't have temples,
and they were an aniconic,
that is they didn't have icons.
They only started to
have temples and icons,
that is physical instantiations
of their divinities,
very late in the day
when they were influenced
by the Christians.
But on their own, they didn't.
And so there isn't
really a physical trace,
not just not a written trace,
but there isn't really a physical trace
of how they worshiped.
But we know something.
We know that they were, as I've
said, that they were pagans.
That means that there
were a number of gods
and the gods were not necessarily divinity
separate from the world.
On the contrary, they were
connected to the world.
They were connected with things
that happened in the world.
This will be familiar from
Greek or Scandinavian mythology.
There, actually there's
pretty strong similarities
between this and Scandinavian mythology,
so if you think of Thor, not
in the most recent movie,
not that Thor, like I
thought the most recent one
didn't really work, I don't
know about the rest of you.
Like I was in Vienna and I
was with a seven year old
and a 10 year old and I took them to see
the most recent Thor movie and like
it turns out that it was like 17 and over.
Seemed weird to me.
And I said like together they're 17,
and they're like, okay.
(students laughing)
And they looked away.
And I took them, but it wasn't really,
I don't think that last Thor
movie really worked, yeah.
Anyway, but if you think of
Thor, the Scandinavian divinity,
you're not far away from Perun
who is a central divinity
in the Slavic pantheon,
a god of thunder associated
with the thunderbolt
also associated with the oak tree.
Another important god was called Svarog
who was associated with
the sun and with the crops,
but the spirits and
divinities were everywhere.
So that's the thing about,
like, about monotheism,
it's not just that there's one god,
it's that that one God is often located
somewhere else besides Earth,
which is a very strange thought
if you're not used to it, right?
Like there's something,
there's something very,
there's something very ascetic
and demanding and disciplined
about monotheism,
where you put God somewhere
else besides here.
Like there's a way in which
it's much more comforting,
actually, to have the gods
kind of around all the time.
Right?
Okay, so the gods were everywhere
and the notion was that
you are in constant
relationships with them,
which explains things that we
now treat as superstitions.
The things that we now
treat as superstitions,
the little physical actions,
are gestures towards the gods.
Sacrifice, human sacrifice,
would be part of these relationships,
sacrificing the right kind of
person at the right kind of,
at the right time.
If you spent any time in the Slavic world,
and you think about it,
you'll notice that the sacrifices to,
the spring sacrifices
and the summer sacrifices
to water and to flame are both
still present in the culture.
They're now ritualized
and nobody gets hurt,
but the rituals are still there.
We can talk more about that if you want.
The dead are still with you.
That's another part of
this pagan religion.
The ancestors will help
you, or they will hurt you.
Your kin relationships extend
to the dead members of
your family as well,
and so you're supposed to continue to do
certain rituals in their direction,
which is not really so
strange if you think about it.
At the end, very important
was the end of life.
The end of life is
something that had to be
very carefully met, very
carefully looked after,
because if not then the dead are angry,
or the dead are irritated and the dead
don't do the things that
they're supposed to do,
instead they do other things,
which is a very fruitful
source, by the way,
for our own culture.
And probably more fruitful all the time.
The, if death is not handled properly,
then the dead are unquiet, and how,
what's an improper death?
If you're drowned, if you commit suicide,
if you're hanged, all these things,
if you die during childbirth,
if you die on your wedding
day, which frankly, I get it.
I mean, that's, that
does seem like bad news.
And if you're not
cremated properly, right?
So religions have ways of
physically handling death,
not just narratively, but physically,
and so cremation is
what's supposed to follow.
The female unquiet death, unquiet dead,
this is still quite
popular in the Czech lands
like if you're have anything
to do with Czech culture
you'll have heard of
these creatures, Rusalki.
Rusalki are water
spirits or meadow spirits
that, again, like a lot of,
actually like a lot of pagan stuff
this shows up in Tolkien,
things like this.
Like, if you know about Slavic paganism
and then you reread Tolkien,
there'll be a lot of things
which pop out at you.
But they sing you, or they
lure you into the marshes,
the Rusalki, so they're very beautiful
and they're very attractive
and they know how to draw
you in, and then you drown.
The, or sometimes they
tickle you to death.
I don't know what to make of that,
but that's a possibility too.
The male unquiet dead
are, it's an easy one,
what's from Eastern Europe, still with us?
Yeah.
- [Student] Is it vampire?
- Yes, vampires.
The male, a male unquiet
dead is a vampire, right?
So, and you know what vampires do.
The vampires, they come back,
they feed on the blood of the living,
they take the souls away, they
start with the family, right?
So when Bram Stoker brought the vampire
into Victorian culture he was working with
an actually existing pagan tradition.
And the reason why, so it
appears, and this is now,
again, this is not from
historical evidence
'cause we don't have it, but it's from,
it's actually from archeological evidence.
It appears that when the Slavs
did convert to Christianity,
which, again, don't worry,
we're gonna talk more about
it in the next lecture,
but when they did convert to Christianity,
there was a vampire crisis,
which you can imagine, right?
Because suddenly nobody was being,
like even if you do convert,
and remember conversion,
like when conversion is
presented retrospectively,
it's like boom, like the leader
dunked himself in the water
and suddenly everybody was Christian
and you know, that's it.
But it actually takes
generations or centuries
and there's usually lots of backtracking
and rebellion and so on.
And even if you convert,
it's a pretty dramatic thing.
And it's very unlikely that
you will instantly get rid of
all of your previous convictions, right?
And when the convictions are
very high stake convictions,
oh, sorry for the pun,
it was not intended,
but when the convictions are very,
like when they're very
significant convictions,
like will my loved ones come
back after death or not,
you may want to hedge
your bets a little bit.
So when the Christians
came the Christians said
no, no don't cremate, inhume, bury.
Right, bury.
But that's not a proper way to die, right?
That's not a proper way for,
and so the way that the Slavs handled this
was to keep, in order to
keep the male dead down,
they put stakes through the bodies
so that the vampires couldn't come,
just in case, just in case, right?
And so hence the notion that
the way to stop a vampire
is to put a stake
through the heart, right?
So these, you know, these things
are very old and very interesting.
All right.
So how do we get then
from no written language
to written language?
How do we get from
paganism to Christianity?
I'm gonna talk about the
details of this next time,
but what I want you to see now is that
the Slavic world was being prepared
for conversion to
Christianity somewhere else.
The first Slavic state is
the Grand Duchy of Moravia,
which is first mentioned in the year 822,
and the first Slavic state, so
Moravia is now in the middle,
the northern part of
what's the Czech Republic.
And it was being contested
between Byzantium
and Western Christianity.
So Byzantium, the Byzantine
Empire, sent missionaries
and these missionaries were Slavs,
because remember there were
Slavic languages are spoken
all over Europe until you
get to Central Europe.
It's a huge amount of territory
where people speak Slavic languages.
So there were a couple of men,
you might have heard of
them, Cyril and Methodius,
who were Slavic speakers,
from probably what's now Macedonia.
They were sent north to
Moravia to convert the Czechs.
And in order to convert them, you know,
their tool was a written language, right?
So as Slavic speakers, they
generated a Slavic language,
which we now call Old Church Slavonic,
and they translated some of
the Bible into this language,
passages of the Bible, and
brought them with them.
And so in the attempt
to convert the Czechs,
which fails, eventually
it fails, but the attempt
to convert the Czechs
generates this language,
and this language is accepted by the Pope,
for a while anyway, as a
third legitimate language
aside from Greek and Latin.
So Cyril and Methodius, it's
a long story, but they fail.
Cyril never leaves Rome,
he's buried in the basement
of a little church called San Clemente,
which if you visit like lots
of people from the Balkans
leave their candles there.
Cyril never leaves Rome,
Methodius does get back to the Slavs,
but he fails to convert the Czechs.
But, and he dies in Moravia.
But here's the interesting thing,
just as a spoken language
is there when you arrive
and it's there after you die,
if you can create a written language,
it's also gonna be there after you die.
So Cyril and Methodius die,
but Church Slavonic goes on,
the written language
goes on, it's taken on,
it's taken up in Bulgaria
by people actually
who are trying to set themselves up
as rival to the Byzantines,
it's taken up in Bulgaria.
The Tsars, as they call themselves,
of Bulgaria, support it.
In Bulgaria, this language
shifts to a different alphabet.
The original alphabet
was called Glagolitic,
but the new alphabet was called Cyrillic.
Not because Cyril invented it, he didn't,
it was, he was dead, it
was named after Cyril.
So Cyrillic, which is gonna
be familiar to all of you.
If it's not familiar, some
of the words on the sheet
are written in Cyrillic, like
I wrote, what did I write?
Oh, I wrote Slovo, I wrote Slovian,
I wrote Nimecy, Nimechchyna.
That's Cyrillic, right?
That's Cyrillic as it was invented,
more or less as it was
invented, circa 893, right?
So you can, if you invent
a language, it can last,
and if you invent an alphabet, right,
that can really endure.
I mean, so the people in
Bulgaria who set down Cyrillic,
if they picked this up,
they could read it, right?
They could read it.
So that's something which was there
before the conversion happens,
and it's very important
that it's there before
the conversion happens
because when Kyiv converts to Christianity
this civilizational package,
Old Church Slavonic,
which is a Slavic written
language, the Cyrillic alphabet,
which allows you to write things down,
is going to be available
with Eastern Christianity.
And so, you know, not that things
don't change along the way,
but here we are more than
a thousand years later,
and it's still, it's an
Eastern Christian country
using the Cyrillic alphabet.
Okay, so that is all generated
for different reasons,
and those different reasons have to do
not just with Byzantium
wanting to convert people.
I mean that's normal,
you would expect that,
but it also has to do with a competition,
which we'll talk more about next time,
between the Byzantines and
the Western Christians.
So this whole, in this, in our class,
we're generally residing
in this trajectory
which goes Greece, Byzantium, Kyiv, right?
But there is this other
trajectory, which is real.
And the other trajectory
there is Greece, Rome,
and then the creation
of this new model state,
this new model state, which has become,
gonna become very important in the world,
where church and state
are sort of separated,
where the states are Christian
but the Pope is not in charge.
That model of state.
And the first important
model of that state
is founded by the Franks,
who we'll talk more about,
but the Franks are the ones
who essentially establish
the political version
of Western Christianity.
The Franks are the ones who stop Islam
at the Battle of Poitiers.
This is like the kind of
thing, so Poitiers is 722,
so this is really, so I'm
not sure to wrote that down.
When I say before Europe,
one of the things I mean is
before the Classical world,
which is a Mediterranean
world and a Black Sea world
becomes a world which is
north of the Mediterranean.
The Classical world is
just as much about Africa
and what we now think of as the Near East
as it is about the European coast.
And insofar as it's about
Europe, it's about the coast,
the northern coast of the Mediterranean,
the northern coast of the Black Sea.
It's not about most of
what we think of as Europe.
So before Europe also means
before it gets established
that north of the Mediterranean
people are going to be
Christians, not Muslims,
and one of the ways that gets established
is at the Battle of Poitiers in 722
when the Muslims are stopped.
In our part of the world
at about the same time,
it'll be the Khazars who
stop, in the Caucasus,
who stop Muslim armies.
Another way that Europe becomes Europe
is not just that Islam is stopped,
but that Christianity
spreads northward, right?
Christianity spreads northward.
The Franks, the other thing that they do
is that they provoke the people
who we remember as the Vikings.
Okay, so much as I'd like to,
I can't completely keep
Western Europe outta the story,
because the West Europeans
do do some important things
like Poitiers and like
provoking the Vikings.
So it's, the Vikings like if you just have
a cartoon image of the Vikings,
the Vikings come and they destroy, right?
Like they're just there to take
the gold from the churches.
But the Vikings were responding to
the emergence of the Franks as a power.
And they responded to the
dominance of the Franks on land
by their superior naval technology, right?
The way that they fought
and the way that they sailed
was a response to the power of the Franks.
This is how history works.
You run into somebody else
who's strong in one way,
you become strong in a different way.
So the Viking Age, which
begins in the eighth century,
is a response to the power of the Franks.
And the Viking Age, although
it includes North America
and Greenland and Iceland
and of course Scandinavia
and of course Normandy,
the north of France,
and by way of Normandy
the remaking of England
into the form that we now
know it, all those things,
the Viking Age is very
important for Europe,
Northern Europe, North America,
our class is also part
of the Viking Age, right?
Because when the Vikings
bump into the Franks
and then set all, and become a
kind of counter power, right?
The power that uses the boats,
the power that's in charge,
that can move, right?
One of the places they get to is Kyiv.
Getting to Kyiv in the eighth
century, the ninth century,
is part of the Viking Age.
So another thing that the Franks do
is they set off the Viking Age
and the Viking Age leads to Kyiv.
So that brings us to where we need to be
when we start the next time.
Byzantium is trying to
convert from the south.
Byzantium is in a contest with the Franks
about which kind of Christianity,
under who's domination.
Meanwhile, the Vikings have been released
and are moving around the north
and are trying to find a
way from the Baltic Sea
down to the Black Sea in their boats.
And the reason why they're doing this,
one of the reasons, is
because of the slave trade,
the economics of the slave trade.
They're capturing and they're enslaving
the people who live, are Slavs, right?
They're capturing those people
and they're bringing them down.
So the metamorphosis
that's going to happen
is when these Vikings have an
encounter with the Byzantines
and decide to become Christians,
and as they become Christians,
the people around them become,
not potential commodities,
but rather become people
to be ruled by law.
And at that point then we can
start to talk about a state.
So I've tried to line up the
things that we need to have,
the religion, the language, right,
a little bit of the economics,
before we get to this
very important moment,
which is the conversion of the
people who are ruling Kyiv,
which is next time.
Okay, thank you.
(gentle electronic music)